partiamo dal punto il sogno non esiste
una definizione universalmente accettata
ha bisogno c'è chi ne danno
un'accensione scientifica check in ed ha
un'accezione sentimentale generalmente
però il sogno per le persone è qualcosa
di bello
qualcosa che ci porta lontano
qualcosa che ci fa uscire dall ordinario
qualcosa che ci fa evadere dalla routine
per me invece la realizzazione del sogno
era una necessità
provate per un momento a immedesimarmi
in una situazione come questa
una situazione in cui tutte le
percezioni contu in con le quali
collaborano sia che stiano a pochi metri
di distanza da tempo che sia una
distanza dei chilometri di migliaia di
chilometri siano tutte affette dalla
sindrome del calimero nero sembra come
se ci sia un'entità superiore che stia
tramando contro di loro vengono messi in
evidenza sempre gli aspetti negativi e
mai quelli positivi
il pessimismo cosmico è degno del
miglior leopardi ci sono sempre le scuse
per giustificare le proprie debolezze e
le proprie sconfitte
bene questo è un momento che deve
avvenire quello che gli inglesi chiamano
bartù un punto di svolta
e il punto di svolta arrivò arriva
quando il numero uno della mia
organizzazione un uomo lungimirante e
che ascoltava la pancia dell'azienda
durante una conferenza mondiale
affermando in un mercato così maturo e
stato come quello in cui operiamo
non abbiamo ragione di esserci non
abbiamo ragione deve esserci se non
siamo in grado di cambiare il nostro
posizionamento di brand verso l'alto sia
in termini di valore che in termini di
percezione due concerti fondamentali se
si vogliono creare delle nazioni
durature con i clienti
la mia organizzazione dalle nostre
nazioni del genere rimasi scioccata
cambiare il posizionamento del brand in
una simile condizione come era possibile
un colpo di persone tra cui è affidato
il compito molto semplice di dover
procedere a questo cambiamento per
cambiare il potenziamento del brand ci
sono molti elementi che vanno toccati
sicuramente si deve partire dalla
produzione da prodotti si deve creare un
prodotto che dia un altro livello di
percezione alle persone si deve lavorare
sulla sua qualità
innalzando culturalmente il livello
senz'altro si deve cambiare il modo di
comunicare
ci sono una serie di elementi che
andavano modificati
però la cosa incredibile che oggi che
finisco straordinaria che avvenne nella
nostra azienda che quando tutti questi
elementi furono a portata di mano e noi
iniziamo a studiarli profondamente ea
metterli insieme
scoprimmo che avevano un unico comun
denominatore l'uomo e la sua cultura
lavorativa l'uomo della sua cultura
lavorativa se vuoi cambiare qualcosa
se vuoi cambiare lo status quo deve
cambiare prima te stessa
devi cambiare il tuo modo di pensare
deve cambiare il tuo modo di agire il
tuo modo di comunicare dell'uomo che è
il fautore del brettone l'uomo che lo
determinano
questo cambio tutto il nostro modo di
pensare cambiò il modo di operare e di
procedere a questo cambiamento il
cambiamento culturale che venne posto al
centro delle nostre attività cultura la
cultura è influenzata da dei valori a
cui ci si avverava nei momenti di
difficoltà la nostra identità la nostra
storia dovevano essere riscoperti e
posti al centro di questo cambiamento
culturale si devono accrescere
convinzioni e senso di appartenenza
questo è un passaggio cruciale se si
vuole che le persone escono fuori
dall'ordinario escano fuori dalla loro
con forza e siano in grado nel ma di
tutto di sfidare i loro stessi e le
regole che hanno seguito fino a quel
momento di grande ispirazione
durante questo viaggio è stata è ancora
la teoria del gold circle
una teoria che è stata presentata al
mondo durante in una memorabile
conferenza telex da simon zanica e
questa teoria afferma che le aziende
devono essere in grado di definire in
maniera molto chiara e precisa e anche
usufruibile da tutti il proprio wipe out
what e proprio perché sono sul mercato
come intendono realizzare con il
prodotto quel servizio e poi ovviamente
cosa realizzano per il mercato a questo
tre cerchi magici lo aggiungiamo un
ulteriore cerchio che era anche in chi
poteva far parte di un'organizzazione
con un tale perché è secondo questa
teoria è bene non invertire mai gli
elementi perché si può incorrere nel
pericolo che simon sane che ci faceva
vedere ovvero che in molte
organizzazioni
succede che la stragrande maggioranza
delle persone conoscono molto bene il
loro quota cosa fanno molte meno persone
però conoscono come lo fan quasi nessuno
quasi nessuno conosce perché è stato sul
mercato e sta sul mercato e sono solo
quelle aziende che riescono che hanno
una cultura incentrata sul proprio
perché che possono creare successo
attraverso il brand
questa è un impalcato una logica che
bisogna seguire bene anche
diffonderla per diffonderla bisogna
creare un manifesto un documento in
questo documento deve essere enunciato
come ho detto in maniera molto chiara il
proprio uguale il proprio il proprio out
per proprio vuoto
aggiungere poi qual è l'obiettivo che si
vuole raggiungere finale che si deve
raggiungere l'obiettivo nella nostra
fattispecie era quella di garantire al
cliente un interim è una esperienza
indimenticabile con il nostro brand
ma come potete vedere in questo
documento ora abbiamo colmato due parti
la parte alta è la parte bassa e molto
lente sono principi per completare
un'opera di trasformazione è necessario
aggiungere anche ulteriori e fattorie
obiettivi che rispondono per lo più a
per classe
il como il comportamento atteso da parte
di tutto lo staff dipendente un ambiente
lavorativo positivo e stimolante il
comportamente attesa della ripresa e che
proprio da quest'ultima che bisogna
partire dalla capacità di questo gruppo
che guida il trasforma trasformazione il
cambiamento di avere una storia
convincente vera convincente e
contagiosa e che perlopiù saper
rispondere a delle semplici domande
perché proprio dove dove stiamo andando
cosa e come andremo a farmi chi lo dovrà
fare
a queste domande molto evidente
il manifesto che abbiamo creato darà
delle risposte che darà convinzione alle
persone che ci devono seguire ma non
sarà sufficiente non è sufficiente
e importante che il gruppo che guida
questo cambiamento sia lui stesso il
primo a cambiare ea cambiare il proprio
stile di leadership e necessario che si
evitino accentramenti decisionali se
invece si predispongono le persone a
poter assumere responsabilità ad ogni
livello e funzione aziendale è
necessario avere un approccio orientato
al coaching fa lo stimolo al dibattito e
non a raccontare come fare un'azione è
necessario che si rimuovano gli ostacoli
e che si dispongano le risorse per le
persone come altrettanto molto
importante definire in maniera chiara e
trasparente
gli obiettivi che le persone devono
raggiungere
perché possano affrontare la sfida ed
avere successo solo per ultimo ma
l'ordine descrittivo l'elemento oltre
molto importante è mantenere sempre alta
la motivazione dell'organizzazione
attraverso un suo continuo
coinvolgimento e l'ingaggio ma solo
questo non porta al risultato bisogna
creare anche un ambiente di lavoro
positivo e stimolante un ambiente che
consenta alle persone di poter
affrontare le stime per uscire da quella
che abbiamo definito la nostra con forza
anche solo quando avremo creato un
ambiente di questo genere allora le
persone saranno in grado di sfidarsi e
di sfidare tutto quello che fino allora
era ordinaria così fa beh ci sono
elementi in questo caso tangibili e
intangibili
partiamo da per semplice il layout degli
uffici e degli arredi con un po più
complicato creare buone relazioni nei
reparti tre le parti creare unicità di
intenti e rispetto reciproco
adesso che abbiamo coperto i due di
elementi gli obiettivi gli ultimi se
tutto questo sarà vero le persone
saranno in grado per intero a un gruppo
di lavoro avrà un approccio orientato a
superare gli ostacoli e non a fermarsi
alle prime difficoltà a rimuovere
procedure azioni stavolta la dose perché
caratterizzate da burocrazie che
processi che non funzionano
saranno in grado di dare un proprio
contributo personale all'attività
dell'azienda ma quello che è più
importante saranno in grado di
condividere e di esternare la propria
passione la propria passione per
l'azienda e per il proprio lavoro
in sintesi quello che dobbiamo
realizzare è avere tanti leadership in
ogni funzione aziendale in ogni fase
tanti liberi perché solo in questo
momento sarebbe in grado di creare il
cambiamento più grande di rovesciamento
della piramide gerarchica e
l'organizzazione sarà in grado di essere
più attente all'obiettivo finale che
come abbiamo detto è quello di garantire
l'esperienza con il brand e
indimenticabile quando lo staff di prima
linea avrà acquisito la leadership di
trasferire il nostro dna
la nostra storia la nostra identità i
nostri valori
il nostro entusiasmo la nostra passione
allora adesso tra organizzazione dovrà
soltanto rimuovere gli ostacoli
distribuire le risorse incoraggiando e
stimolando lo staff quando ci sono dei
momenti difficili celebrandolo però nei
momenti del successo quando questo sarà
realizzato allora avrà la cosa più
grande sarà avvenuto il cambiamento nel
posizionamento di brand perché il brand
sarà cambiato all'interno
nell'organizzazione e noi saremo pronti
a poterla trasferire all'esterno
trasformare se stessi per modificare se
stessi è una delle attività più
difficili che possono farsi ma vi
assicuro per mia esperienza personale
che anche l'attivita più motivante
stimolante che abbia mai fatto in
vent'anni di carriera
l'esperienza di questi cinque anni ha
fatto sì che un gruppo il cambio di
rimedi che sia stata trasformata in un
gruppo di bellissimi c gli impianti
decennio è un animale che difende il
gruppo che non ha paura è che a
differenza del lavori che ostenta la
bellezza è bello di per sé e non ha
bisogno di essere sulle nostre stazioni
in un mondo come quello attuale
contraddistinto dalle grandi tecnologie
dove si parla di intelligenze
artificiali di robot che devono gestire
l'uomo il mio vuole essere un richiamo
alla centralità dell'uomo luogo il
fautore delle grandi rivoluzioni e
l'uomo che determina il cambiamento è
l'uomo che raggiunge i propri obiettivi
quindi spero che questo sogno non
riguarda soltanto la mia organizzazione
ma possa avvenire ovunque e voglio
chiudere con la citazione di una frase
di un architetto tedesco che per tutor e
non
annuncerò perché difficilissimo e per la
quale sull'uomo
c'è un uomo sogna da solo quello rimane
soltanto un sogno se in molti sognano
insieme
è l'inizio di una nuova realtà
grazie a questi a palermo